this video is part of an epic collab and
hashtag team trees but more on that
later
hey crazies most of you probably get the
basic idea of photosynthesis plants pull
water up from their roots inhale some
carbon dioxide from the air and use
energy from the Sun to power a chemical
reaction it's basically how they eat but
like a lot of things in biochemistry
it's a little more complicated than that
photosynthesis is wild
[Music]
actually plants are not the only thing
you can photosynthesize yeah yeah I know
organisms like algae and cyanobacteria
can do it too photosynthesis has been
around a lot longer than plants have
it's just easier to talk about plants
because they're more familiar to people
hashtag team trees alright because some
of you may not know this but I'm married
to a biologist she helped me a lot with
this video so if I get anything wrong
it's her fault it's my fault it's always
my fault anyway
something I've learned from our
conversations is that in biology there's
always a deeper level where you can ask
more questions think of them as various
levels of abstraction at the top you'll
find our original explanation for
photosynthesis plants use water carbon
dioxide and sunlight to make food down
at the bottom is the full atomic level
which is usually unnecessary and often
overwhelming to the point of uselessness
as a physicist I like to see how deep I
can go before that happens so let's do
this so far photosynthesis is like one
big mystery box the water carbon dioxide
and sunlight go in and then glucose and
oxygen come out that glucose is a sugar
and sugar equals food but that visual is
pretty misleading it gives you the
impression that if you have a bunch of
water and carbon dioxide and you shine
some light on it then the molecules will
just rearrange themselves which is false
if that were true you could get the same
reaction to happen by just shining some
light on this carbonated water the truth
is none of those molecules can absorb
enough light to react like that
they need help a lot of help there's a
lot going on in this box let's go deeper
in reality the water and carbon dioxide
aren't even used in the same stage Stage
one is where water and light come
together to make oxygen and some energy
the oxygen is released some of which
makes it out to the atmosphere the
energy is passed on to stage two where
it's used to transform carbon dioxide
into something called a sugar precursor
it isn't actually turned into the sugar
glucose until stage three technology
became that sugar precursor can become
all sorts of sugar not the glucose are
you gonna be on the case the whole video
if you keep messing up yea-ah he's right
as usual but this process is going to be
complicated enough I've got to draw the
line somewhere so for the rest of this
video
Stage three makes glucose just go with
it we're going to focus most of our
attention on stage 1 because that's
where light goes in and oxygen comes out
photo means light so we should focus on
the light reactions to understand how
the heck that works you know where we
need to go deeper the process that
happens in stage 1 is called the z
scheme because some of its parts kind of
look like the letter Z there are five
separate parts each taking in some
particles and spitting out others I
warned you this was gonna get involved
but it's worth it I promise
Part A splits water into an oxygen and a
bunch of ions that's four electrons and
four protons usually those protons are
labeled as ionized hydrogen or H+ but
I'm a physicist not a chemist I'm just
gonna call it what it is a proton as I
said before the oxygen is simply
released but most of those ions are
going to get used in the rest of stage 1
Part B is where the magic happens light
comes in and gives up its energy to an
electron knocking it loose one of the
electrons from Part A quickly falls in
to fill the gap left behind the loose
electron is free to move on to Part C
how the heck does that thing work
chlorophylls
Deemer each plant cell is filled with
little green packets called chloroplasts
chlorophyll being inside chloroplasts
that's not a coincidence
biology is real big on prefixes and
suffixes inside each chloroplast
there are even smaller Pancake things
this is where stage one is actually
happening on the surface you'll find a
lump of various pigment molecules many
of which are chlorophyll which give
plants their distinctive green color
each of those pigments can absorb a
different color of light as you can
imagine the more light a plant can
absorb the better off it is so the more
variety of pigments the better a pair of
special chlorophyll hang out in the
central opening that's where our
electron is attached light comes in the
appropriate pigment absorbs it and that
energy gets passed around until it gets
to that middle chlorophyll the electron
is knocked loose and another falls in to
fill the gap the mechanism is actually
kind of cool we call it a photosystem
and there are two photosystems in stage
one of photosynthesis so what happens
with that loose electron it's got some
excess energy we can use that electron
hops from molecule to molecule in Part C
making biological energy along the way
well it's not like it's loose energy
floating around that's not a thing
energy is just a property but in biology
the word almost always refers to ATP a
biologically useful molecule that stores
energy this molecule is constructed from
stuff already floating around nearby the
energy from the electron is given up to
combine those parts into ATP that's all
Part C does it makes ATP Part D is
another photosystem light comes in and
electron is knocked loose and the
electron from Part C falls in to take
its place
part-ii is another assembly machine but
instead of assembling ATP this one
assembles something called NADPH
biologists and their acronyms just think
of it like a little bus that carries
electrons around
seriously they call it an electron bus
it just helps the cell move the
electrons over to stage 2 that's it
nothing crazy this is what stage 1 looks
like overall for simplicity we're only
showing the molecules that get moved
around
unfortunately for stage 2 to actually
work properly we need three of these to
be running simultaneously that's the
only way to give stage two all the
energy and ions it needs to work and
that's where the carbon dioxide comes in
remember the carbon dioxide plants can't
grow without carbon Stage two happens in
the main space of those green packets
inside the cell three carbon dioxide
molecules come in along with a bunch of
energy in charge from stage 1 through a
process called the calvin cycle those
molecules are turned into cgp
I mean g3p that's the sugar precursor we
talked about earlier which will be made
into glucose in stage 3 wait a minute it
takes two of those g3p molecules to make
a glucose that means the cell needs six
stage ones and two stage twos
just to make one glucose that's forking
ridiculous so how do photosynthesis well
plants and other photosynthesizing
organisms use water carbon dioxide and
sunlight to literally make their food
this process is nowhere near simple
though a whole bunch of complex chemical
processes are used some molecules need
to be added to this system
but others continuously cycle around all
just to make sugar molecules that allow
them to grow and continue to exist so
were you prepared for the complexity of
that process let us know in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
this video is part of an epic collab at
hash tag team trees so crazies
let's talk global warming climate change
whatever you want to call it it's the
greatest challenge humans have ever
faced and it's our fault that's even
happening speaking of challenges back in
may 20 19 reddit challenged mr. beast to
plant 20 million
as a celebration for hitting 20 million
subscribers and to literally no one's
surprise he was crazy enough to attempt
it unfortunately that's a lot of trees
and he can't do this by himself so he's
partnered with the Arbor Day Foundation
and recruited hundreds of creators
across multiple genres to make it happen
myself included photosynthesis is still
the best control we have for carbon
dioxide levels in the atmosphere so the
more trees the better for every dollar
we donate to the Arbor Day Foundation by
January 1st 2020 they'll plant a single
tree in a forest that needs them one
dollar equals one tree ten dollars
equals ten trees a hundred dollars
equals a hundred trees of course that
means 20 million trees is gonna take 20
million dollars
hence needing to recruit all of us to
spread the word just so you know I'm
putting my money where my mouth is I'll
be donating a hundred dollars to the
cause if you can donate there's a link
in the doobly-doo if you can't donate
that's fine too just share this video
with others like it to spread the word
let's do this hashtag team trees this
was a special video today so no featured
comment I'll get to those next time when
I get back to my normal routine thanks
for watching
[Music]
you